hi everyone my name is Tamara chambers
and this is Tamara's never seen today I
am watching the Star Wars holiday I love
Star Wars I've seen everything stars I
grew up with Star Wars shocked surprised
I know I just I just I love Star Wars
and a loved Star Wars thing I haven't
seen the Star Wars Holiday Special
I've heard that it's bad but also I just
love Star Wars so much and I really want
to like it or went out for the Jedi
cheers to us and a happy life day
[Music]
let's see I've got Yoda I've got Vader
Yoda you weren't in this one let's use
you because you are still good and nice
in my heart so let's just okay here we
go
I don't know what that song was but it
was better than the entire special
hooray so basically what this is is Star
Wars was popular so they were like let's
make a Christmas special barely put in
the lead characters and then we'll just
throw in a bunch of weird and at times
sexual music numbers the Star Wars logo
shows up at the very beginning and it
was like Star Wars Holiday Special
starring Mark Hamill with a lot of
makeup and Harrison Ford as Harrison
Bourne Carrie Fisher's she was also born
possibly on vicodin I'm upset that
Chuy's dad is named itchy it's a
disgusting name but his wife is is
smoking love his wife she was definitely
the best actress she's stunning and I
think I look a lot like
[Music]
so question I watched this on YouTube
because it wasn't anywhere for sale I
could not find it for sale online I do
not like to stream things but if it's on
YouTube
I have to imagine it's just like fair
use but there were no subtitles there
had to be subtitles in the original one
because like it's the first like 15
minutes of Chuy's family walking around
living their everyday life getting ready
for life day I think but I don't know
because there were no subtitles what
were they doing 3/4 of that could have
been cut out at this point I still
thought it was gonna be pretty
story-driven versus just a bunch of
weird sketches and so I wrote down and
then Chuy's son the creepiest saddest
one of them all watches a hologram dance
[Music]
okay it's very odd it's a very odd dance
there's like all these little hologram
guys and Chewie son is like what the
fuck what this was what I started to
realize like the no subtitled Chewbacca
wookie is fine whatever I'll get over it
but this was the first time when I was
like they just spent four minutes on
that uh-oh then Chuy's wife mala does a
search for the starships in the area and
there is no Chewbacca to be found and
she was very disappointed and she's not
the only one then you see Mark Hamill as
Luke Artoo's there would have fun with
fun party Oh Oh mark you have so much
makeup on live your truth same but then
nothing happens then you see darth vader
and it's like yes finally amazing this
will be fun this is now gonna be
bearable 200 always gone
but by then there's a entire scene where
Chuy's wife mala is trying to make the
ICANN gets called to banthus surprise i
honestly trying to block out like i'm
trying to get rid of it completely from
my mind because it was pointless was
another like five to six minutes uh why
was she making mr. hipster we put is
itchy watching porn just in the living
room she is using a VR headset she watch
porn in the living room I now hate the
name it she even more cuz it's just now
it's so gross it's like this beautiful
black Elsa talking about fantasy and
sexual desire a bit sensual for a moment
but then you're just like this is stupid
as hell it's also four minutes with the
bomb just like Mall photo background she
looks terrified for four minutes
straight Star Wars I wrote down yeah
it's Leah Leigh is back yes oh it's hot
well you get to see you Leia finally and
it's a very pointless some stormtroopers
arrived at Chewbacca's home I think
they're looking for Chewbacca honestly I
don't know I was chopping potatoes for a
suit at this point because like I just
couldn't I just couldn't but then this
guy distracts one of the the main
stormtrooper guys he distracts him with
a music video and it's another four
minutes and it's just a Jefferson
Starship music video Star Wars Star Wars
this was 30 cents at a thrift store
because no one cares about Jefferson
Starship so lumpy Chuy's I'm sorry I
hate that name as well you've got mala
and you've got Chewbacca pretty badass
names but for some reason it skips a
generation because Chuy's dad is named
itchy and his son is named lumpy fluffy
is watching this animated short it's
about ten minutes by far the most
interesting part of the movie then
they're like okay everyone has to watch
Amanda
Tori screaming of life in Tatooine
because we honestly we just can't fill
up two hours oh the Arthur was great
love service yes yes yes yes yes
short memory a Thorpe short memory Han
Solo and Chewbacca make it back in time
for life day what a surprise
the last 10 minutes are I think the
Wookiee celebrating life day and they're
in like this weird like cosmic plane and
and they all have these red robes on and
like weird candle things and they're
celebrating life day I think then Leia
comes out and sings for ten minutes and
I just watched ah ah nothing could have
prepared me for this this was a dumpster
fire of a holiday special it was so
disappointing to see these characters at
such a low point this special could have
easily been 15 minutes they could have
cut out every single song every single
like weird skits maybe leave in Bea
Arthur cuz she was hilarious but changed
why she was there prediction number one
haha here's a quote from George Lucas
regarding the special if I had the time
and a sledgehammer I would track down
every copy of that show and smash it
that's great to hear
you will speak fluent Wookiee by the end
of it all you will never want to see
Mark Hamill and mascara ever again
people hate that but I kind of love it
live your truth Mark Hamill and you'll
be confused for delighted because it's
quite odd yet somehow lovable I didn't I
didn't find it I didn't find it quick
stir stir stir stir quit you will wish
for wookie subtitles so there weren't
subtitles I predict you'll have deposit
at least every ten minutes max just to
have a break from the non-stop wookie
noises I started it up and it was so
slow and there were no subtitles and so
I started chopping onions and then
potatoes and I
made some delicious Zuppa Toscana soup
and then it was still going so I made
homemade bread from scratch and it was
still going after that I didn't laugh
once during this I thought it was super
boring Doug was like there's only about
maybe 10 minutes out of the whole thing
that are so bad they're funny and I
would say that that's the whole be
Arthur whole chunk it's like it's so bad
that it's funny and at least a little
entertaining the rest is just hot fire
garbage and I hated it I have seen the
Star Wars films a lot of times and and
so to see something completely new with
them all in their costumes at all as
those characters from a time that you
can't get anything new from now is
really amazing but it was it was just so
disappointing Carrie Fisher in something
like I really wanted this to be good but
you know the really the one thing that I
will say is that they really did get the
music choices right
I don't even know I have those I've
never listened to them next week I am
going to be doing home alone - we all
know how much I loved home alone one oh
thank you so much for watching this you
all let me know what you would like to
see for the rest of December and I will
see you all next week
[Music]
[Applause]
you